bonjour inscrit dieu merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur rt france un
ministre iranien vient d'évoquer je cite
une victoire en quoi est-ce une victoire
pour téhéran
et qu'est ce que cette annonce de la
cour internationale de la justice va
changer il vient c'est une victoire
puisque ça permettra en fait à l'iran
d'avoir un mode de dermik race juive en
plus avec celui que fait l'union
européenne déjà pour essayer de ramener
le nul dans l'accord et en ça ça peut
être considéré comme une victoire
puisque déjà il y à un mécanisme de
résolution des différends qui éclaire la
commission mise en place par l'accord et
qui déjà dont va se charger d'arbitrer
le différend qui est actuellement depuis
2000 visites entre les ailes du nez puis
l'iran et on ça cette nouvelle puisque
ça se produit les moyens d'arbitrer et
de pouvoir peut-être ramener les deux
états à la même table de négociation
vite que c'est un nouveau moyen
d'arbitrage en plus de celui l'union
européenne justement le ministre des
affaires étrangères de l'iran mohammad
javad zarif a suggéré que bruxelles
pourrait servir de juge dans ce litige
mais quelle marge de manoeuvre pour
l'union européenne entre t on d'un côté
et et washington il ya toujours eu un
rôle d'arbitré est que je vais parler
une parmi européenne que ce soit depuis
2003 puisque lorsqu'il y avait une
grande innovation diplomatiques et
économiques effectuées par les avions
vis-à-vis de l'iran
ce sont vraiment les étals la france
l'allemagne et le royaume uni qui sont
parvenus jusqu'à téhéran pour pouvoir
rétablir des pourparlers et puis il ya
eu un marathon de 12 à les négociations
diplomatiques que des pompiers d'avancé
le phase de stagnation
et puis de parfois de nos pubs mais
toujours avec un indirect politiques qui
avaient été maintenus par l'union
européenne même si l'intérieur du
président ahmadinejad qui était perçu
comme un conservateur et puis l'union
européenne à cette marche de valeur
lorsque elle est un grand partenaire
économique des états unis
et puis un soutien quand même aliment
puisque elle a cet intérêt à conserver
cet accord pour lequel elle s'est battue
qui le montrent ces décos massy et donc
sa marge est quand même brandon
puisqu'elle a toujours été considéré par
un mardi par les deux parties et qu'elle
a cette légitimité
à san juan y est affirmé ce matin ne
vouloir changer aucune clause du jcp oh
ah le fameux accord sur le nucléaire
iranien ont signé à vienne en 2015
pourquoi une telle déclaration bien
c'était un peu pour prendre d'ailleurs
la raison principale pour l'accueil
donald trump s'est retiré de l'accord
c'est parce qu'en fait il ne voudrait
pas la question de missiles balistiques
iraniens qui peuvent acquérir une charge
nucléaire est donc en quelque sorte on
tournait l'accord qui a été signé en
2015 et puis la question du nucléaire en
drame du majestic iranienne est
considéré par l'iran comme très
importante pour sa sécurité nationale
il ne souhaite pas tranché dessus et ça
a été la raison pour laquelle femme
s'est retiré de l'accord et ça reste on
ce sila en mai 2010huit donald trump a
même déchirée cet accord est depuis mai
2018 à chaque fois il ya des périodes
auquel
l'iran se désengage au fur et à mesure
au souvient récemment c'est un
désengagement pour produire à nouveau de
l'uranium enrichi à 20% c'est que c'est
au niveau de 80 90 % pour avoir un
uranium enrichi pour pouvoir
confectionner par exemple à la bombe
atomique on en est encore très loin
est-ce que l'iran peut revenir sur tous
ses engagements pour justement se créa
soir à la table avec les états unis les
états unis qui ont déclaré qu'ils le
pouvaient de nouveau retourné dans le
jcp loi c'est anthony blinken qu'il l'a
dit la semaine dernière si justement
téhéran ce revient 2 sur 7 des
engagements
il vient tout est possible puisque
justement à ce niveau de cet accord
conditionné la levée des sanctions
internationales obtenues via
l'américaine européenne en 2015 2016 si
justement l'iran acceptait de se
conformer à ses engagements issus du
traité sur la non-prolifération
nucléaire et puis après donc le panier
d'accord et il existe toujours
cette conditionnalité entre la levée des
sanctions
et puis le fait que l'iran respecte
l'accord et on voit que l'iran ne s'est
pas retirée comme les états unis de
l'accord l iran est toujours dans cet
accord donc un retour une sorte de
retour n'a rien de bon sens dit et à ses
engagements est toujours possible si les
sanctions sont levés
mais du côté des états unis on voit
également que pour lever ces sanctions
il faudra la conditionnalité de voir
l'iran respecté à nouveau c'est ses
engagements les etats unis ont déclaré
récemment que la cour internationale de
justice n'était pas compétente est ce
que ça un désaveu pour washington ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
considéré spécialement comme un désaveu
puisque la cour en question est un
organe de l'organisation des nations
unies en revanche pouvoir nommément
d'arbitrage en fait dans le différend
qui les oppose tous les deux de la
caisse merci à se réduire d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en sciences politiques
et sociales de l'université catholique
de louvain